foreign
hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again now in my recent discussion over
on my scare Salon Channel where I broke
down all of the VHS series of films I
admitted that I was not the biggest fan
of found footage which you know anybody
that knows me already knows that because
I kind of say it all the time but I did
concede and I do concede that there are
several examples of the subgenre that I
actually quite enjoy and think are great
movies and one of those is the movie
that we're going to be talking about
today which I actually saw many years
ago I can't even remember the first time
I saw it but somehow like I never got
around to reviewing it so I thought even
though I said that it was going to be a
while before I did more found footage
yeah I'm going back on that promise
sorry about that
um you know because I was like well I
really have to get around to this one
because this one is kind of like an
iconic uh found footage film so this is
the 2007 Spanish movie Wreck
now the movie It's conceptually I'll
agree not really all that original
um but it succeeds really because of its
claustrophobic setting I think that's
like a big thing it has a very very
tight like action-packed run time it's
really short it's only like an hour and
17 minutes or something like that so it
doesn't [ __ ] around
um and it also has like a somewhat
unique explanation for what is
essentially like a zombie-esque like
outbreak sort of narrative but it has
kind of a little bit of an original
cause which you don't really see in a
lot of movies now like a lot of found
footage movies and I kind of feel like
this is probably like the main reason
why a lot of people don't like them is
because it has like a lot of shaky Cam
and a lot of kind of like you know
there's scenes where there's just all
this chaotic movement and you're really
not sure what it is that's going on this
movie does have that some but I kind of
feel like in this case and I'm not
really sure why but in this case I kind
of feel like
um the visual confusion here actually
enhances the horror rather than
detracting from it as sometimes you see
in like some maybe lesser examples of
the sub-genre I guess because this one
you really get the sense that you as the
viewer have been plunged into this
hellish situation like right alongside
all of the characters who are all
they're not real clearly delineated I
mean other than the main uh the main
lady who's like the TV host but are
still like relatable enough just like as
human beings they're just like you know
just randomly sketched in but you can
still like get a sense of them as
characters and there aren't a huge
amount of characters anyway because it's
kind of a one location film I kind of
feel like that's the thing I kind of
feel like the whole point of found most
found footage movies I feel like is
they're trying to immerse you in this
situation making you feel like you're
there and a lot of them really don't do
that but wreck totally totally does so
Rec was written and directed by uh two
guys whose names I'm sure I'm going to
butcher
Plaza uh I think that I got that sort of
right uh and it was actually shot in
Barcelona now it was such a critical and
Commercial hit it actually made 16 times
back like its two million dollar budget
um that you know an American remake was
probably inevitable and in 2008 we got
one it was called quarantine
um and it actually retained a lot of the
film's plot and kind of like aesthetic I
guess but for some reason
um quarantine like changed the whole
inciting cause of the outbreak which I
don't know that was kind of a weird
decision I'll talk a little bit more
about that later but I mean I remember
seeing quarantine a while back
um and thinking it was all right like I
thought it was like pretty decent like
for an American remake of a foreign film
but you know as with most of these types
of situations I feel like the original
is a great deal better and if you're
only gonna see one of them I would
recommend the original obviously uh
wreck actually then I didn't know this
until today actually but it um spawned
three three sequels for Christ's sake
because everything has to be a franchise
these days uh Rec 2 actually came out in
2009 REC 3 Genesis came out in 2012 and
then Rec 4 apocalypse came out in 2014.
I can't really comment on those because
I haven't seen them like I said I didn't
even know they existed until today
um but it does seem just from a you know
peremptory kind of like look at all the
reviews and stuff that Rec 2 seemed to
get a pretty positive reception from
like critics and fans and stuff
um well you know obviously like as it
went on in the franchise I feel like
reviews of like the latter two films
were a little bit more like mixed to
negative so at the start of wreck we are
introduced to kind of like our main
character she's a TV presenter named uh
Angela Vidal and she's played by Manuela
Velasco who I think was in three of the
wreck movies I don't think she was in
the third one but I think she was in all
the other ones so she's kind of a host
of like it's kind of like a documentary
reality Style Show which is called while
you're sleeping uh the premise of this
show I obviously is to go around and
kind of like interview people who work
nights or who are otherwise up to
interesting things at night like while
everybody else is sleeping obviously
now on this particular night Angela and
her I believe never seen cameraman Pablo
like he's referred to all the time but I
don't think like he's ever shown
so they're doing a piece on firefighters
at a Barcelona like fire station
now at first obviously everything seems
normal and uh matter of fact like Angela
is kind of like getting bored she's not
really sure if this firefighter piece is
going to be interesting enough for the
show because you know obviously anybody
that knows anything about firefighters
most of the time like when there's not a
fire or another kind of call like an
emergency the firefighters just kind of
have to wait they just kind of have to
sit around so it's like sometimes they
take naps or they play cards or they
watch TV or they're like in the dining
room eating or whatever it is they're
doing so they're just kind of like
sitting around so um you know waiting
for something to happen so Angela like
while she's interviewing one of the guys
she even jokes to one of the men she's
like well don't you know kind of don't
take this the wrong way but I kind of
wish that something would happen like
not a fire not anything bad or anything
like that but just something would
happen so they would have like something
to film so they're not just like sitting
around in this fire station because like
she said she's getting a little bit
bored and she wants kind of something to
like spice to show up you know well soon
enough uh you know careful what you wish
for because soon enough she gets her
wish so a call comes in from a Barcelona
apartment building like nearby now it
isn't a fire they know that and
initially they don't really seem to be
in a big rush because the report said it
didn't it didn't sound like all that
serious what it was was that it seemed
like there was this older woman at this
apartment building and she's like they
guess like fallen down or like hurt
herself and she's kind of acting weird
like acting erratically she's up in her
apartment she's screaming her head off
and a bunch of her neighbors like called
the police and a couple of officers have
already arrived there like when the
firefighters got there so the other
residents of the building who are all
like cranky and you know in their
jammies and robes and stuff because you
know it's kind of like late at night and
they've been woken up they're just kind
of like standing around in the lobby
like when Angela and Pablo get there
being like yeah we don't know what the
[ __ ] was up with that lady she's just up
there like screaming her [ __ ] head
off and we don't know why we think she's
probably hurt so Angela and Pablo are
able to convince a couple of the
firefighters whose names are Alex and
Manu to allow them to kind of like
follow their movements upstairs they're
like you know this will be really good
for the show you know what I mean so
hopefully not that serious but it'll be
like good TV you know what I mean so
they want to follow them upstairs like
while they go up and check on the
women's well-being now the cops are
going up there too they're not super
happy about it but you know they
eventually like kind of concede that
they can come up there
so they go into the apartment
that belongs to this old woman
um her name is Mrs is Kyoto is Kyoto is
I think that is how they said her last
name
um they go in there and uh it looks like
she's kind of in bad shape uh she's kind
of like gesturing very strangely or like
kind of a little bit aggressively and
the front of her nightgown is like
covered with blood and they can't really
figure out which so she looks like
pretty [ __ ] up now when the police
officers approach her like to see what's
the matter she basically just like jumps
at them and bites one of them in the
neck like tearing this big piece of
Flesh off so there's all this
pandemonium obviously uh the woman gets
temporarily subdued and the officer that
was bitten like everybody just kind of
like you know gets together and Carries
him downstairs like hopefully to get
some medical attention when the gang get
back down to the lobby however they
discover that they suddenly are not
allowed to leave the building uh cops
and the military have surrounded the
place and locked them in but initially
will not tell them why they have done
this uh and then very suddenly Alex one
of the firefighters is actually like
thrown over the third floor railing to
his very gruesome death like on the
tiles of the lobby floor in what is
actually like a really really good like
jump scare because just he suddenly just
like Splat like on the floor like that
um naturally everybody flips the [ __ ]
out at this as you would and at this
point you know there are like yeah you
guys can't leave and they're like the
hell we can't so Angela and Pablo start
like you know trying to get like helping
out the residents like how they're
trying to find another way out of the
building obviously but pretty much
everywhere they think of a like to turn
to uh there's more cops and more
soldiers and then like as they're kind
of like struggling they're like maybe we
can go on the patio maybe we can go out
like through the attic or whatever
um you know the building has now
actually been covered with like plastic
sheeting so it's almost kind of like
like they're bug bombing the place you
know what I mean like it's all just like
closed off so from that point wreck
becomes essentially like I said a zombie
movie
um only it's one that's confined to a
single three-story apartment building
with really no way to escape now
eventually they do let a health
inspector guy and he's got like all the
gear on and everything like he comes
inside and he basically tells all the
people in there that this very highly
contagious disease has broken out in the
building and they're trying to keep it
contained but whatever they're doing is
obviously not working because this
infection which is seems like something
like rabies and they do say later that
it probably like came from a dog like uh
at a vet in the neighborhood and so this
rabies-like infection like continues to
spread throughout like all the people
trapped in the building and it takes out
pretty much everybody until Angela and
Pablo are the only ones left pretty much
uh so then there's like this really
really the final like very very
frightening final sequence has them kind
of just keep it going up and up and up
they're trying to like I said they're
trying to get out like through the roof
or something like that because they
can't get out any other way and so
they're trying to find Refuge too and
this supposedly empty like Penthouse
apartment like the guy that manages the
building told them you know somebody
owns it but nobody lives there like so
it's usually empty but when they get in
there uh they actually discover
instead what is like the Horrible Secret
of what probably caused the infection in
the first place so as I mentioned you
know so so the plot of wreck is not
anything particularly novel obvious
obviously it's like a zombie outbreak
type of narrative but I think the the
winner here is like the execution I mean
it keeps like the pedal to the metal
like pretty much the entire time and
puts you like up close and personal with
like all the events as they unfold I
have to say too that I think it was a
really smart move to add in this whole
extra layer of the mistrust of the
authorities kind of angle because
there's a thing where like the none of
the officials outside obviously they've
trapped these people in this building
and they won't tell them what's going on
and so inside like the residents are
thinking they don't care they just like
locked us in here to die like once they
figure out that like there's an
infection spreading so the fact that
they have this whole like um you know
anti-authority thing where they're
afraid that the government officials
outside aren't telling them anything
that gives Angela and Pablo in
particular because they're TV reporters
like an impetus to want to film
everything that's happening so that like
when we get out of here we can prove
that there was a cover-up and we can
blow this case wide open and all this
other kind of stuff so it gave them a
reason to like keep filming
um you know because that's the thing and
I think I brought this up on the VHS
thing was that I think that's kind of
like a a thing that you always have to
like get around with found footage
movies is you know you always have to
keep explaining like why people why the
people would keep filming when like a
normal person would have stopped you
know what I mean so they did actually it
was like really believable in this movie
like why they would keep doing what they
were doing
um also like in the final sequence I
liked that when they got up to the
penthouse like um you know the the light
on the camera had broken like earlier
and they get up to the penthouse and the
powers out and so then they have to use
the camera like for the night vision so
they can see because you know obviously
they couldn't see otherwise so I think
it was like good they maintained like a
good level of like credibility like
throughout like why somebody would keep
filming in that situation now as I said
the revelation of the cause behind the
outbreak like while unusual and
admittedly a little bit implausible like
it's a little bit strange but it was
still like refreshingly different
um it kind of brought something of like
a supernatural via science angle it's
almost like a scientific possession type
of thing
um and that's not usually something that
you see in a lot of zombie type movies
so I think like the fact that the
infection was explained in these terms
was really one of the things that made
the movie Stand Out and that's why it
was like sort of mystifying to me that
the American remake kind of did away
with that sort of intriguing backstory
and went with something like more
standard you know what I mean which I
don't know why they did that I mean
quarantine like I said I'm not gonna lie
it's still a decent movie but wreck was
definitely like a bit more inventive in
that regard because at least it had like
a little bit of an original take on it
so I mean if you're at all into found
footage I mean wreck is right up there
with like all the best examples of the
sub-genre and I feel like if you have
any interest at all in the form in that
sub-genre then probably this one is one
that's kind of like required viewing you
know what I mean uh it's a really
fantastic example of the principle of
less is more
um you know what I mean it's just
basically just one location just a
handful of characters it's very very
tightly uh contained very tightly edited
and it really maintains like a high
level of scares with just like I said a
few characters in a very very dangerous
very confined space and it also has one
of the creepiest like final sequences in
recent memory like when they find what
is essentially like patient zero that is
some [ __ ] up looking [ __ ] and just the
way it's filmed like through the night
vision is really really effective and
like really really creepy so that will
do it for this flickers of fear and I
will see you guys again on the next one